You can also join the discussion on The David
Pakman Show sub Reddit, which you can find at
David Pakman dot com slash Reddit. That's
our edited. Nearly 30000 of our viewers and
listeners are now subscribed free to The David
Pakman Show sub Reddit. Some interesting posts.
I like this one. Someone posted to David's will
never see on Fox News again me after my last Fox
News appearance and David Leopold, the immigration
attorney who we covered earlier this week,
who called out Fox host Judge Jeanine Pirro
over the weekend. I think that is fair to say.
I don't think I will ever be back on Fox News.
Actually, you know, I don't know that I don't
think I'll be back on the weekend news hours. The
Fox Fox really each show is its own thing. I think
it's plausible that I'd be back on some other
show, but I don't think they'll have me back on
the weekend America's news headquarters after
my last appearance. And yes, I don't think David
Leopold is going to be back on Fox News anytime
soon. User Portland hipster suggests that I start
referring to Donald Trump as a former one term
President Trump and that it will trigger, quote,
right wing kooks. Yeah, I think that the syntax
former one term President Trump. The I think that
it makes more sense to say the one term former
president Donald Trump or just the one term
president Donald Trump, yeah, I like that idea.
I think that that's definitely an adjustment that
I would easily be able to make on the show when
referring to Donald Trump and then user what the
Chinese posted about anti vax math, pointing out
that the U.S. has seen 30 million I'm sorry, 30
million dollars, 30 million confirmed coronavirus
cases. The real number could be anywhere up to,
you know, two to three times higher than that.
Five hundred and fifty thousand covid deaths.
One hundred and twenty five million vaccine
doses administered. Now it's closer to 130.
Nineteen hundred vaccinated people that died
and no one that we know of who has died from
the vaccine. And yet appointive AXA's somehow seem
to think that the vaccine might be more dangerous
to them than coronavirus. Yeah, of course the math
doesn't work. And what you have to also remember
even about. So there's a lot here that's even
understated, right? We have no deaths linked
to the vaccine. That's true. But even deaths
of people who died after being vaccinated,
when you vaccinate tens of millions of people, by
sheer math, some of the vaccinated people will die
from an actuarial perspective of old
age, of other conditions, et cetera. So
I think that it's very important to put this math
in perspective. It's also important to remember,
you know, on anti vax math, what else are anti
vaccines scrutinizing to the degree that they
claim to be scrutinizing vaccines and ingredients
in this type of thing? I mean, do they ever eat
junk food? Do they understand what all of the
elements are in junk food, on the ingredient list,
when they buy shampoo, when they buy skin creams
and toothpaste and whatever, are they scrutinizing
the I don't know if they're called ingredients
when it comes to health and beauty products, but
are they scrutinizing everything that
is in those products to this degree?
There is definitely a it's sort of like sometimes
people become there's this thing, orthopraxy,
where people become fixated on diet to a degree
that that's unhealthy. It's almost like a
diagnosable condition. And you start to wonder,
you know, what else do you obsess about to this
degree in your life outside of your diet? And
maybe we should apply some context. I think the
same thing applies to many antibiotics is where
great. You're really concerned about what's in the
vaccines. That's fine. Are you equally concerned
when you get antibiotics? Are you equally equally
concerned when you buy Tylenol or are you equally
concerned when you look at junk food? Have have
you ever looked at the ingredients in zebra cakes?
And I'm kind of half kidding. Maybe zebra cakes
don't have anything that crazy in them. I used
to love those as a kid. I really did. Zebra cakes
anyway. Joined the discussion on The David Pakman
Show sub Reddit, David Pakman Dotcom Reddit.